en 2018 les néonicotinoïdes insecticides
accusés de contribuer à la disparition
des abeilles ont été interdits mais les
produits chimiques ne sont pas le seul
fléau affectant l'environnement les
températures très élevées en 2020 ou
favorisé la prolifération des pucerons
ces derniers ont transmis une maladie la
jaunisse aux betteraves la filière
française du sucre déjà fragile a perdu
30 à 50% de sa production
46 mille emplois sont menacés on évalue
à 100 millions d'euros le manque à
gagner
la loi sur la biodiversité de 2016
impose le principe de non régression en
matière d'environnement
et pourtant face à la crise de la
filière du sucre l'état a rétropédalé un
nouveau projet de loi prévoit des
dérogations pour réemployer les
néonicotinoïdes il sera examiné le 5
octobre
ceci provoque la fureur des apiculteurs
écologistes militants anti pesticides
élus de gauche mais aussi parfois de la
majorité pourtant la nouvelle ministre
de la transition écologique barbara
pompili bataillé ferme contre le tueur
d'abeilles
mais c'était en 2016 on les écoute quoi
qu'il arrive en 2020 c'était fini pour
tout les néonicotinoïdes mais ces
derniers mois elle a bien été obligé
d'avaliser la décision gouvernementale
et d'avaler des couleuvres mais elle ne
cache pas son opposition à celle ci ce
choix que j'ai dû faire avec julien de
normandie le ministre de l'agriculture
me met très en colère elle a même signé
une pétition pour faire interdire des
pesticides
les agriculteurs se plaignent de ne pas
avoir de solution de remplacement qui
fonctionne contre certains insectes
ravageurs et professionnels de la
filière ont remis le 22 septembre
ministre de l'agriculture un rapport
contenant des engagements ne ré emploi y
est l'insecticide qu'une seule année en
utiliser moins faire des recherches pour
trouver d'autres solutions dans des
fermes pilotes mais les opposants au
néonicotinoïdes préconise d' indemniser
les agriculteurs d'effectuer des
rotations de cultures et d'accompagner
la baisse inévitable de la production
soit une réorganisation de la filière
affecté par l'arrêt des quotas plutôt
que l'emploi de produits nuisibles pour
l'écosystème et parmi les parlementaires
la bataille fait rage
ceux de la majorité voteront pour la
dérogation à condition qu'elle se limite
bien aux betteraves
car d'autres agriculteurs souhaitent se
faufiler dans la bresse mais d'autres
élus qui ferraille depuis des années
contre le tueur d'abeilles soit la
bloquer écoutons joël labbé sénateur du
morbihan sous le poids des lobbys des
betteraviers notamment mais de
l'ensemble des tenants du modèle
agricole productiviste
le gouvernement a cédé et propose ces
dérogations mais encore faut-il qu'il
passe au parlement donc en lien avec des
associés des associations
environnementales des professionnels de
l'apiculture des organismes agricoles
des scientifiques et un certain nombre
de délits politiques concernés les biens
on se mobilise pour essayer de faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de majorité pour
voter ces dérogations
en réalité si comme le prévoyait la loi
les agriculteurs avaient été accompagnés
dans leur transition sont
néonicotinoïdes les solutions de
remplacement du tueur d'abeilles aurait
pu être déjà trouvé cela aurait évité
cette bataille stérile du sucre contre
le miel